okay so I'm sure everyone's seen it but
there's this satirical Japanese
convenience store haul video going
around this guy gets like some Band-Aids
and egg salad sandwich some tea and some
other stuff and I think the joke I think
the joke was supposed to be you could
get this stuff anywhere but if you buy
it in Japan it's amazing because wow
Japan hahaha very funny um
the premise doesn't really work for me
and that's because all of that stuff is
better in Japan like try having an egg
salad sandwich outside of Japan than
making that video and look yeah I say a
lot of positive things about Japan but
that's because there are only positive
things to say about Japan right like I
can't be up here talking about some
problem that doesn't even exist I say
the things that I do not because I know
that Japanese people well not because
there's some motivation or I'm thinking
I don't even know what I'd be thinking
about
um I'll tell you what this guy was so
low that he was making fun of
traditional Japanese convenience store
culture like he's definitely not going
to apologize for it so I will Japan I'm
sorry
and one other thing to this dude like if
you can only have a good time here when
you're disparaging a rich element of the
culture then you're clearly still in
your backwards foreign bubble so just
kind up your bags and go home like Japan
doesn't want you here we don't want you
here okay believe me
sorry that sounded a little bit negative
so
let's end this video on a positive note
if you like Japan then like this video
and if you love Japan then subscribe
like can we get a like and a sub for
Japan okay cool and maybe in the next
video we can go to a
traditional Japanese Western coffee shop
that sounds amazing I'm already pumped
okay I'm gonna end the video here but
I'll talk to you guys again soon
sayonara
thank you
how do they fall for this every time
more easy money